angry people sound like
gloomy types we certainly don't usually
think of them as
optimists and yet beneath their gruff
surface
they truly are much to their cost
here is fred he is often
furious he's been married to his wife
jane for 15 years
he's often told her not to interrupt him
when he's reading the newspaper
she finds this prohibition annoying for
some very good reasons
so tonight she's asked him quite frankly
when he'll get around to cooking dinner
now fred is shouting because he is
deep inside so hopeful
fred often loses small household items
today he has lost his car keys he is
furious where the hell have they gone he
asks his family and fury
fred is shouting because he is deep
inside
so hopeful fred arrives at the airport
his flight is delayed by four hours it's
an outrage
especially as he's one of the airline's
premium passengers
he goes up to a young woman at the
check-in desk and tells her
exactly what he thinks fred
is shouting because he is deep inside
so hopeful despite all the evidence fred
keeps encountering
he stubbornly and devotedly maintains a
faith in a world in which
his partner understands him small
household items don't go astray
airline schedules are more than a
fiction all his experience
stretching back many decades has not
dampened the intensity of his crazed
hopes
and every time they're dashed he screams
fred will never be able to remove the
frustrations of his life
but he could perhaps if he were wise
with the help of philosophy
learn to change what they mean to him he
might learn to accept
reality for the sadder thing it truly is
he might take on board a series of dark
truths about existence
that partners never understand one
another very well
that we're constantly losing things that
matter to us and that travel is filled
with delays
more broadly he might realize that life
is outside of the old brief sunny patch
a
sequence of disappointments
misunderstandings sorrows griefs and
eventually catastrophes
fred could learn to get a lot less angry
if only he learned to stamp on all his
hopes
more effectively most of us are in many
ways
a little bit like fred but our agitation
isn't permanent or unbudgeable
it's only the result of the sudden
defeat of our expectations
so in order to grow reliably calmer we
need to get
a lot less optimistic about how life
might go
pessimism is the cure for anger
you